president trump sparking another media
firestorm critics up in arms this time
over a new york times report about the
president wanting the justice department
to prosecute hillary clinton as well as
former fbi director james comey
some in the media sounding the alarm
about trump's intentions
and this is a defining moment in the
history of the trump presidency because
this
is a demonstration of his unfitness to
be president of the united states
of his abusive presidential power of his
embrace of authoritarianism
now this news i want to be clear with
you is a scale way beyond anything else
we have seen in legal controversies
with donald trump this is what happens
in authoritarian countries the president
orders
the president the leader orders the
investigation and prosecution of his
political enemy
but supporters argue that trump has been
saying this for a long time
like during the presidential debate two
years ago
if i win i am going to instruct
my attorney general to get a special
prosecutor
to look into your situation because
there has never been so many lies
so much deception by the way so
dana you have a situation here where
people you know like uh
alan dershowitz today on steve's show
said
you can't do this you do not use
political you don't use the criminal
justice system to punish your political
opponents
what do you think well i think that um
you can say a lot of things right inside
a white house you could say i want this
to happen and then you might have a
general counsel that's very wise and
smart and clever
like don mcgahn who says it's not a good
idea mr president we're not going to do
that
and so his lawyer is bill burke he's
being represented bill burke is
full disclosure good friend of mine but
he says mcgann was not going to comment
on the legal advice he gave to the
president but he noted
that the president never to his
knowledge ordered anyone
prosecute hillary clinton or james comey
so again it's like
so he might have brought it up like
maybe like you're in a
you're frustrated like well they're
going to investigate me like investigate
her i want you to investigate her sir we
can't do that okay but i'm like we're
not going to do that
and they move on um when they say that
this is what happens in a dictatorship
no what happens in a dictatorship is
that the prosecution actually happens
and it's not a fair trial there is no
due process and that person is
immediately
thrown in jail or extradited or
something like that
um that's not what happened in this case
so that's what i would say
and steve what would you say to people
who say why is he discussing this and
then others said as you saw on the tape
that he's been saying this during the
campaign he was saying oh yeah
if i'm president i'm going to get my
special prosecutor but mcgahn and others
told him
this could result in your impeachment mr
president sure uh
and we had uh when the conversation
you're talking about juan where we had
alan dershowitz
in this studio this morning he said it's
not impeachable but it's just dumb
he should not have done that but i tell
you what he really amped it up
the uh then candidate donald trump
because it's one thing for you to say
when you're out on the campaign trail
but then when you were sitting or
standing right next to the person and
saying
if i win big trouble that's something
but that's donald trump but it sounds
like rhetoric on the campaign trail but
when you're actually proposing i think
is what set people up so jedidiah you
hear these claims of
authoritarianism you hear people saying
this is worse than since watergate
what do you think it's ridiculous i mean
what's the story here i'm still trying
to figure out what the story is he
didn't prosecute
anybody actually you have his legal
representation coming out and saying
yeah we didn't we didn't hear him say
that he was actually going to prosecute
anybody
it's just so interesting that now the
new york times has gone from
stories where they actually thought they
were going to find collusion now they've
decided well we didn't find the
collusion we were looking for so now
they're they're
writing outrage stories about things he
might have said
that might have happened and now you
have cable news heads explosion
exploding over this
i just i don't see the story he didn't
prosecute anybody he didn't do anything
about it
it's not it's not a story if somebody
says oh yeah i'm gonna do this and then
nothing actually
happens i don't know what are we
supposed to be upset about i mean even
if you have to restrain
the president the most powerful man
first of all how do you even know
that you actually had to restrain him
this is taking don mcgahn wrote a memo
so the memo exists
he wrote him okay so but but somebody's
saying and also like
it's not just because he wasn't just
saying these things because these people
were right you know for example comey
for example oh these are his
adversaries he was saying it because he
had legitimate concerns about hillary
clinton
and bleaching a server and taking a
hammer to her server and saying
listen i'm gonna you know i think this
should be looked into and that was a
point that resonated with every american
sitting at home saying
what comey did seems unreasonable which
he did seems unreasonable and it was it
was a selling point for him to say
this doesn't look right how this went
down and i think it should be looked
into
that's very different from him mandating
prosecuting his enemies
and actually following through like a
dictator he's not a dictator nothing
about this is dictatorial okay so greg
what do you make of this
um if you took every outrage that the
media embraced
that was born from trump venting you
would have
nothing all right his venting is defined
by thinking out loud
and wondering what possibility is out
there that could solve something that
bugs him
and then somebody says something to him
and he goes okay then he finds something
else
trump is a salesman and a businessman
and what do you do
when you enter a new job you ask a bunch
of questions some of the questions are
incredibly stupid
and that is why donald trump is
different than anybody in the media
because the media is too insecure to ask
stupid questions it's almost a superhero
power that trump has
his willingness not to feel shame
when he's wrong and when he asks a dumb
question hey can i prosecute her you
can't prosecute her oh okay
there's this kind of amnesia that that i
read about where you forget whatever is
absorbed
that same day so every new day is new
the media
has trump amnesia they wake up every day
as though it's the first day of the
presidency
and they freak out in fact i don't know
why his critics are so
fat because they're always up in arms
they should be so
fit they should be so good because
they're always like this
screaming they should be like on the
cover of men's health
instead they're just bloated how are
they so bloated
when they're so screaming all the time
because um barack obama campaigned on
closing gitmo
yeah remember yeah okay and do you guys
remember the other story that on the
on his first day in the oval office
after he's sworn in he's
sitting around there and he's like okay
where's the paperwork yeah
i'm gonna close gitmo yeah and his staff
says oh sir you actually can't do that
yeah
actually something has to go through
congress he's like what do you mean i
can't do that everybody
can't do that because the law says and
that's why you have smart people around
you that can advise you on things that
you might not necessarily know about
that are detailed
in the law so greg just a quick response
to what you said
you i think that the liberal side would
say are we normalizing
what is very unusual behavior the
president trying to use the justice
department to punish
no i i think that a the word normalizing
should not be normalized
i hate that word uh number two i think
we're seeing the the trump amnesia the
psychology of this
is people are exhausted by him okay
and so here's an experiment if you
erased trump from today you'd have the
largest peacetime expansion probably in
history dramatic declines in poverty and
violence
worldwide aside from syria and
afghanistan things are looking pretty
good there's a lot of prosperity there's
a lot of fresh ideas
and new technology it's it's a simpler
but somehow complicated life with
technology
so my point is despite this there's a
sense of doom around the corner
everybody thinks something awful is
happening even though the physical
evidence is telling you
there's optimism everywhere and the
reason is because all of this is a
psychological problem
this is a psychological problem it
certainly isn't a physical one
all right all right i guess that's why
you know that's why he has like 30
something percent
no it's actually higher than that or
misrepresented that all right and then
and then there's president trump saying
it's a no-brainer
on who he thinks should be named time
magazine's
person of the year it's called person of
the year right
it's no longer man of the year right
okay
i don't know that's up to time magazine
i've been there before
i can't imagine anybody else other than
trump
[Laughter]
even you find that funny well you find
that funny is he serious
i mean he's i think he's partially
serious i don't know i think that i
think that's just how he is though this
is like people who don't get that
still just don't get trump but that's
just how he feels he feels like hey
listen i'm the president i'm doing a
whole bunch of cool stuff
i could be mad at you i don't think
they're gonna pick him but but one
uh person of the year or man of the year
or thing of the year
uh you know i looked it up and
apparently it is the
greatest influence on the events of the
year wow has influenced
more things in the past but maybe maybe
on
on the merits it'll be him it could be
fun but it's going to be pelosi
right she's going to get more things i
just think that she's going to get
person of the year they go
they just they're at 39 seats flip she's
going to be speaker again
it's not a man it's a woman i'm just
telling you on the merits
trump might deserve it but i am putting
my mark down
and you're rarely wrong on this i will
say you know what's great
i thought we're going to talk about the
correspondence dinner there's another
example
of where trump made something better the
dinner has now returned to its roots
which is about the importance of
journalism after decades of celebrity
worship
it was the curse of the press you know
the insecure and homely
in the media you know always wanted to
be near the cool kids
trump cured them of that yep i agree and
now that they're that they don't have a
comic
after him yes he's gonna and then he
said he might go and then he'll be the
funniest speech they've had right he'll
be the funniest speaker
i'm sure it'll just be uproarious i can
see it you will be laughing
you will be like no i can't laugh you
know because people say juan was
laughing at the president
no laugh with the president